hey everyone welcome to live coding with
Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're going to
do a shorter than normal stream because
I have a meeting in less than an hour
and also we're doing something that may
end up being a little bit boring we're
doing some data transfer so it needs to
be done I I need to get all this data
transferred there really soon because
I'd like to have I'd like to be done
with it be done with the data transfer
and just finish out getting a test
version of this site available on a
public URL for everyone to try give us a
month before we need to launch you know
to have as many people as possible to
test it and get feedback so that's why
we're doing just some data transfer
stuff you know on the stream which I
usually save for when I'm not streaming
but I thought it might be useful to show
it and I'm a little bit a little bit
tired today
my daughter Cordelia who's one and a
half just wanted to party last night so
she didn't feel like sleeping so if I if
I sound a little like less enthusiastic
than normal that's why so I want to try
my best to fight that ok so let's get
started
let me switch my view and the first
thing I'm going to do is just introduce
you to the code we're using the migrate
so it's been a long time since I've I've
showed this code on a stream so you may
not be you may not be familiar with it
unless you watch I don't know maybe two
months ago would have been the last time
we showed it so this was basically built
by one of
the viewers so Harshit built this and
I've modified it depending on the type
of content that I need to bring over but
what we're doing is we're bringing in a
few packages which this is no js' in
particular we have sequel eyes and fetch
so sequel eyes helps us to get data from
a sequel database in one case going from
one type of sequel database to another
type of sequel database so sequel server
to my sequel so we're we have our
database info right so name password
everything we need to actually get in
there and I can connect to this database
but only from this computer that I'm at
right now and only if I'm on a certain
network so I'm a little bit limited in
and what I can do
so we're connecting to the sequel server
database and then we're pulling out data
so we have the sequel query here and
this is just using a template literal
right through to write a sequel query so
I manually modify the sequel query based
on the data that I'm getting so I'm my
other screen I just have an Excel
spreadsheet that I created from that
database that gives me the content of
each what do you say like each row in
the Excel spreadsheet gives me one item
in the database and I can see the
content I could see the folder ID and
that's what we're using the folder ID is
the key piece of content so we want to
bring over the content ID the title the
content HTML the teaser the date created
from our content table where folder ID
is whatever we set it to in this case I
just imported everything from 4 to 441
and then
length of content hTML is greater than
zero so there's there are a lot of items
in the database that have no content at
all I don't want to bother bringing them
over so that's why we have this piece to
filter out so we're grabbing all that
and then the next step is let's insert
it into my sequel database so that's why
we're using fetch that's why we imported
fetch here note that so and the browser
now depending on your browser you would
automatically have access to fetch but
this is server-side so we have to bring
in notif a CH or something like that
there's another package called
unfettered it will do the same thing so
we're going to use the WordPress API to
put the data into our my sequel database
because we're using WordPress to manage
that database so why not just use the
API and it will make sure that that data
gets put in in the proper order in just
the right way that we're press likes so
that's why we ended up doing it like
that so you can see here we we take our
WordPress a URI so basically we have the
URL we already have the URL that we're
trying to send it to here and then we
just add in the post type that we wanted
to go into in this case I was adding it
into graduate program it was a post type
that I just created a few minutes ago to
handle some of that data we have a few
other options here that are commented
out but if we needed to make some
changes to the titles we're using some
regular expressions to do that in this
case we don't need to or I didn't need
to for that last post type we also are
doing some things to manipulate the date
so that the date gets into the the
format the dates in and the old server
is not the right format we need for the
new server so we do some stuff to make
sure it is in the right format and then
this is the how we format the data
so we basically just take the data in
the way that the wordpress API wants it
and we just plug in what we've gotten
from the sequel server so a wordpress
doesn't want content HTML they want
content C so we just put it in the right
the right way and we just do a simple
fetch right and we just send that data
to the right place and then the word
president API takes care of all of the
rest and they're actually inserting that
into the right place and in my sequel
database so that's it I mean it's it's
it works it works really really well but
it's not it's not super complicated to
go through it so let's do some some more
migration let me say hello to everybody
I see this
so you're saying hi I see there's
already a few questions let me let's do
it like this what time is it okay let me
start my plumber over timer
I'm gonna do one Pomodoro session and
then I'll answer all the questions after
that up until maybe about five minutes
until 3 p.m. Eastern time and then I'll
have to stop and go to a meeting okay so
hang in there if you've asked a question
or if you want to ask a question I'll
get to it in about 25 minutes
so for now let's we're gonna basically
be here for most of the time if we need
to make another custom post type we're
going to be here if you're interested in
the plug-in that we created to handle
all these different custom post types
and taxonomies this is now on the github
repo so if you go to that FUS marcom
github organization this is the latest
repository there I've added that plug-in
which that's that's new I just did that
last week before that I wasn't tracking
it with git
all right so I have on a few of my other
screens I have some some data already
set up in terms of like that spreadsheet
that I told you about and just a list of
items that I've as I've gone through
boating the site I've noticed like hey
we don't have this data yet so owners
program pages pages all right so let's
see here's here's my process let me drag
some of this over to the screen
and here's my oops maybe we're gonna is
this a bit better let's pull this over
here there we are
okay so what I've been doing is
basically just searching the site to
find out some of the pages this is the
current website some are ancient and
Biblical Language Institute so I
currently don't have any of the data for
this program that we have so our ancient
language institute oh that's a PDF I
definitely don't need to worry about
that right now
oh yeah so I go in here and just try to
find see like alright how many pieces of
data are we looking at four or five
maybe like five pages so not really a
lot occasionally these pages will be
broken up into different pieces of data
so it may be more than five that we're
looking at and then I'll grab some of
the text and usually it's it's just
enough to grab like seven or eight words
and then I go over to my spreadsheet
which I'm gonna pull this over so that
y'all can see it ISIF old over here so I
go over to my spreadsheet this is going
to be really small it it doesn't really
matter to be able to read it it's just
like the concept of how I'm doing this
so I paste that in and try to find it it
looks like it's not here
that's not good news so well it may or
may not be goodness it could mean that
I've already brought it over and didn't
realize it at the time that I brought
that data over
so yes
let me try to grab just some other piece
of data from here let's see maybe this
one the other possibility is that this
page has been edited since I made a copy
I had a copy made of the database and so
this date is actually newer than what I
had so that's what I'm gonna try to grab
another piece of data and try to do a
search with that there we are
okay so it looks like where we are able
to find this awesome so this is a little
bit small so you may not be able to see
it but I found a few pages that do say
that that's si BL Institute and now I
can look over here at the folder number
and it's 346 and if I look every piece
of data here in that 346 folder all have
to do with that same Institute so it's
safe to say we can grab this
everything in this 346 folder and
categorize it in in our new database as
as that type of data so let's see I know
I just lost it 3 4 or 6 yeah this
spreadsheet is a little intense
now I want to make sure it seems like
I'm missing a page 1 2 3 4 why is there
only 4 1 2 3 4 5
let me see what this pages see this is
like part detective work
alright this explains why I only have
four piece of data because this page
doesn't really have content it's pulling
other content that we've already brought
over but just in a different post like
these this content is stored under our
faculty profiles so we've already pulled
these over so that explains why so I did
I need to be really careful to make sure
that I don't miss parts because that
could be a mess later on when you know
I'm trying to launch in people were
saying this page doesn't work this page
doesn't work and so this is good this
this should be fine sa POS yeah so we
may need to make a custom post site for
this so let me bring over and show you
what we have going on in WordPress so
right now okay we do have a post type
for Institute's let's check out if we
have anything in there yet what you
gotta be kidding me
I have this Institute citations in
languages all right let's see really
ancient writers you know or just for
immersion we may I may have already
brought this over if so that is
excellent course credit descriptions
let's see if we have
Wow and it's already categorized you had
to be kidding me
so this is really good news
unfortunately I didn't when I first
serving over data I was just bringing
over a ton of data and I didn't take the
time to mark down what I was bringing
over and so occasionally not often but
occasionally I run into this where I've
actually already brought over data but
it was so long ago that I didn't even
remember so this is great now what we
can do is go in here and delete these
rows I made a copy of the original
spreadsheet I was working off of what in
this one every time I verify the data is
there I delete the rows so ideally what
will happen is once I have no rows left
I will know that I've transferred every
bit of data so that's the idea I just
have to make sure I'm very careful so
that that in fact this is really the
case so it looks like for sure
everything in this folder here I can go
through but also we have this Veritas
Center which I believe I saw that in
there as well we can verify that there's
a I thought we had it in here oh there's
two pages let's see confidence
oh you know what I guess I gave them
their own custom post type so where it's
uh so we do have Barrett saw stuff in
here there's a Center for Bioethics
do I have that it doesn't seem like I
have that particular piece of data oh I
do I have it here Veritas Senate
Republican all right I will have to
figure out what the heck is going on
with that because I don't really see why
I would want to separate out those two
two different post types but I have
verified that it's there so we can
delete that as well that's great and I
can mark that off my list and next thing
on the list are honors programs which is
awesome because I just happen to have
the honors program pages right here all
right honors program it looks like we
only have three three pages here I'm not
sure let's verify though and we can get
rid of this and this will go back to our
search honors program
okay so this is actually treated as if
it were a major in terms of where this
content is on the site and the URL it's
given so it's the same way as as we
would treat a program or a major so
that's interesting and we also have two
different URLs for this we have one with
a hyphen and one without a hyphen
I bet they go to the same page they do
we'll have to make sure we account for
that and our routing if we haven't
already about all right so it looks okay
like we have that honors program the
great thinkers requirements
list information there you got
requirements is here under Honors
Program as well and then Austria so
those are the three things we need and
none of this is okay good so we have
this Honors Program stuff what I think
we'll do then is we'll put this data in
the same place as we would put other
majors and things like that and I think
we'll categorize it underneath the
classics category we already have since
that's where it's being categorized
right now we probably should verify that
it's not already there so let's go into
our majors section type in honors Honors
Program Quick Links so it looks like we
don't have everything I wanna share your
Quick Links
okay so we do have one piece of data
here but not everything so let's pull
this over then so we need a few pieces
of information and that is the folder ID
which looks like it's 340 so we're gonna
put in 340 into here and then in this
case we want this to be under the major
post type so we're going to type in
major and then we also want to make sure
this isn't the right category so we have
this faculty department taxonomy and we
have to get the category ID so let's go
back over here where WordPress is and
make sure we can get the right ID so if
we go to faculty Department and we go
over to classics if I hover over it the
URL shows up really small at the bottom
and that URL has the ID number which is
19 that's the fastest way that I found
to just get the ID right away with a
fewest number of clicks so I get 19 so
now I can go back here type in 19 and
that's all we have to change and now I
can just run this so I'm gonna run node
my grade is because that's what this
file is called that we're working in we
can do my grade j/s and see it's you
know it gives us a little message here
of you know here's the sequel query that
we're running and then here's how many
posts we brought over which is three
which is what we expected I cancelled
that out just by pressing ctrl C now we
can go back over to WordPress and verify
that that data is there now so if we go
back to C
classics that's the category we went to
and click that it will give us all the
classic stuff we should be able to see
yep we have the Honors Program front
page honors program requirements honors
program for students in Austria and we
could look like that and see how this
comes through it's actually not bad
right we can see the the raw HTML here
it's not too bad you know we've got H
ones and things so there's occasionally
weird stuff like right down here we just
have an H 5 just hanging out and empty H
5 I'm gonna get rid of that I don't
clean up the data always I just wanted
to show you what it's like
eventually I do want to go through and
clean it all up and it's not a hundred
percent necessary before launch at least
not for most pages I mean ideally I also
wouldn't have like an h1 to h3 and an h4
all right there at the top it's a little
odd but oh no that's not really bad that
you know the state is coming out of a
totally different content management
system and we're able to pull it into
WordPress and it it basically works so
I'm just going to update that but we can
see it also pulls over the correct
publish date so this data was actually
published in 2014
long before I was working here but this
gives us a way to keep track of like how
old is the data actually so that's why
we're bringing over the original publish
dates otherwise everything would seem
like it was published this year which is
definitely not the case wonderful so now
the next step would be make sure I get
rid of this data in the spreadsheet it's
just just those three pieces I'm gonna
delete that and then on my other screen
I just have a checklist in Google keep
so I'm just checking things off as I go
through and I do want to at this point
check how much time I have left see if
we can get into anything ok about 7
minutes and I see there's a lot more
questions in there I'm not I'm not
ignoring the live chat forever I will
get back to it in about 7 minutes
let's see I'm gonna try to get one more
type of data in and depending on what we
have I may even need to make a custom
post type here or a taxonomy category
see jobs
okay I need to get HR profiles so this I
might need an another custom post type
for this so first I want to try to find
where this is on the website so don't
think about area Human Resources I won't
need to search for this one I I know
where it's at in the menu
I think that's these are where they were
yeah
so there's this whole section of why I
chose Franciscan and its people that
work here and it's their story about why
they they work here so the data that I
really want is this here and you know
this image as well but you just be a URL
linking that image for now so that's
that's what we want to find so once
again I'm just gonna grab some of this
data and I'm gonna go back over to our
spreadsheet I'll paste that in and
search for it no couldn't find it via
the strata grabbed it from somewhere
else
you gotta be kidding me
oh thank you I maybe since I had
highlighted those sections it was only
searching in that section so alright
great so it looks like we have these the
same names of the people that we just
saw up there and this is in for 615 so
let's double check that while this
profile is actually for the head of my
department
I believe the she's the executive
director I think that's her title great
so let's bring over everything here in
the 615 folder and when I create a new
post type and these are gonna be H or
profiles as far as I can tell they are
definitely different from some of the
other profiles that we've we brought
over so let's create the post type first
and then we'll bring them over so we we
do that we have an option actually so we
already have we can see in WordPress we
have an HR section so we could just
bring these over into HR into that
section Human Resources and perhaps give
them some sort of category or something
that would say like okay these are our
profiles we want to use either way we
have to set up something either a custom
taxonomy or a custom post type I think
it'll be easier right now to do a custom
post type it's something that could
definitely be changed at some point
let me see what the URL looks like this
is going to be the probably the big deal
actually how the URL structure is whoa
that's awful
I don't know if you can see that URL but
that's no good all right so I don't know
what's up with that one but this one
let's see all right so are you are
structures HR slash profiles slash and
then we have a last name - first name
Charlie what would it be it would be the
easiest way to bring this in all right
let me think about it just just for a
few seconds I'm trying to think how how
our router works in our server dot JS
file in our react site
I think will be fun I think yeah we'll
be fine to just pull this into our HR
pages I don't even think we need a
category yeah I think we'll be okay
there's gonna be a slight chance that
this data could be pulled in if you type
in a different URL but I'm not worried
about that
it won't conflict with existing URLs so
I think we'll be okay all right so let's
go over to the site this will make it a
lot faster
so let's verify was that 6:15 okay I'm
at six
yes so let's go 615 615 and let's go
human human resource I think I did let's
let's make sure that I did it like that
human resource yep
so when you bring it in in here it has
to be the singular so it sounds a little
weird to say human resource but that's
how I named it and we need let's let's
go with
let's clean up the names first all right
so we're gonna clean up our names and
we're gonna add that to the slug that'll
help us
it may not perfectly get the slugs how
we want it but it'll get them a lot
closer and I think that will be easier
we might luck out some of them might
have the right slugs automatically we
won't have to manually change them so we
don't need this faculty department and I
think we think we're good and that's
what we need
all right so let's save that run it
there we are we got six of them it's
stop that process and then now we can go
back over here check out our human
resources and see all night so we do
have now these people here and let's
check out our slugs so I do I want to
see how it works with someone that has a
doctor in their name where the slugs
come out I make all right awesome those
slugs are actually perfect so it's been
so long since we did that regular
expression I couldn't remember exactly
what it would do but it actually is is
perfect it reverses the names you have
last name first and then first name
takes out doctor or any title like that
and as the - so we there will be no need
for us to go in and manually adjust
those slugs and you can see we have URLs
and fortunately they are relative URLs
so once I eventually transfer all of the
image the images from where they reside
now to our wherever I'm gonna have them
later on as long as I keep the same
folder structure all those relative URLs
will still work so to save a ton of time
and that should work so I think yeah it
won't work automatically right now
because I need to set up a few more
things in the router but otherwise as
soon as I set up that route in our
server
AS VAL those should work fine they
should be good awesome
so my timer is is up I think so what I
need to do I don't need to push anything
to github because all the changes we
made we're just transferring data we
didn't make any changes to code so now I
got to keep an eye on my time so I make
it to my meeting on time but I'm gonna
go back to the chat and let me check off
check this off on my to-do list here
it's always nice when you start checking
things off and you see that that's
getting shorter but I am now I'm gonna
spend the whole rest of the time
answering your questions and checking
out your comments in the live chat tech
techie gang says sir I just graduated
and have moderate knowledge in HTML and
CSS what should I do to get a great
start in career if you want a career as
a developer like a web developer then
keep learning more about HTML and CSS
but then also learn some JavaScript as
well start into that so I recommend if
you if you have some time now start with
free code camp if you already know a
little HTML and CSS the first few
lessons are going to be really easy for
you but then you'll you'll move into
JavaScript
and that'll give you a nice foundation
so if you go to free code camp org
that's a great place to start there are
a lot of other resources but you know it
kind of has a simple answer to your
question I would start there and as soon
as you feel comfortable start building
some projects set up your get your
github profile and put your projects on
github after you get a few projects made
get more comfortable you can start
applying to jobs and you know you gotta
you have
real shot at becoming a developer you
know depending on how much work you can
put into it you know somewhere maybe in
the next year even you'd be ready to get
a good job so I mean it's different for
everybody it depends on a lot of the
factors but you know it's it's
definitely a possibility
javascript is here hey what's up harsh
it's here and Nicki
everybody's here yeah that we have all
our other regular people I think are in
here awesome
Harshit says yeah I remember that file
yeah that's honestly hard that that has
been great I usually constantly for
migrating data whose work perfectly
javascript says why not use algo Leah
for search instead of powered by Google
so this is the the search that we were
talking about I was going to type in rug
because I'm curious to see whether or
not we have sports pages on here anyway
this website I've had very very little
to do with it was developed before I
started working here so a lot of the
decisions pretty much all the decisions
were made without me
really I've the only work I've done on
this is just really really minimal
things like if something looks really
bad sometimes I get to change it I did
do some work to try to make it faster
and I did make it significantly faster
but it's still really slow like if your
load times are like a hundred and sixty
seconds on 3G and you cut the load times
in half your site is still insanely slow
right it's does 80 seconds load of time
so I percentage-wise it was impressive
how I cut the load times but it's still
too slow which is a big reason why we're
completely redoing the site so anyway in
JavaScript that's why we're not using
algo Leah because I had no say in that
hey Dmitri says I Jessie how are you not
bad I'm a little bit tired but other
than that I'm okay
anyway how are you doing if you're still
here to meet you let me know Michael
says just remember to build a queue for
a 4-page before launch just in case you
know what I actually put that in as an
issue in the github repo that we need a
404 page I thought about it sometime
last week and I I thought I definitely
need to make this an issue so I don't
forget
Chris s it's that HTML inside your
database yes I'm I'm pretty sure I know
what you're talking about like what with
that and what I was shown on the screen
and yes like the the actual HTML comes
over
michael says instead of deleting out of
the excel why not add a you know a yes
or no column for imported and filter out
for blanks or no that way you want to
accidentally delete something that
probably have been a better idea at this
point I'm just gonna keep going with
that with what I have I do have a copy
of that excel sheet that doesn't have
any of anything deleted that I can refer
to if I if I need to if later on I
realized like I'm missing something I
can always double check on that and I
still have the actual database that is
still intact so there's a few ways I
could still find that but anyway Michael
that that probably would have been a
better way I just didn't think about it
JavaScript it says I forgot how does one
shoot a vid or do a live for free code
camp um you could try to like make a
video on your own and then send it to
you probably want to talk to Bo Carnes
you could try starting to Quincy but I
think he usually says like talked about
this Bo handles a lot of like bringing
people into the channel and letting him
know like he did like some training with
me
when I came in and Bose actually the one
that saw my live streams on my channel
first and then invited me to come onto
this channel so I would get all to him
on Twitter through Eva or something like
that and let him know you're interested
you're gonna send them a video that
you've done something like that and then
that's you know you just go from there
good didn't manone I'm not sure how to
pronounce that but given in US isn't
there a better way to do this if anyone
knows a better way to do this let me
know the problem that I found is that
the data is so separated out I I can't
bring over large chunks at a time if I
wanted to be organized
on the other side there's no there's
just nothing I could find the only I
could find that even remotely groups
data into reasonable groups is that
folder ID and there are so many folders
that I have to go through and say okay
what is in this folder
what should we categorize it as and then
bring it over so there was some chunk
some folders that had a lot of stuff in
it and I was able to bring over like 700
things at once
and that was awesome but now I'm getting
to the point where all the folders that
are left only have a few things in each
folder so it's just kind of slowing the
process down a lot I mean really if
anybody thinks there's a better way to
do it that would be easy to implement
and switch to and get through all the
rest of it you know let me know I'm open
to trying but at this point I've
migrated more than half of the data I
hope and so just some counting in it
like stick with what I have and get
through it
dextra of world says what CMS was it a
CMS a content management system just in
case you know familiar that term it was
called Ektron our Aniki says is Ektron
yeah yeah and the new CMS is WordPress
the old one is Ektron so X Ron is not
very easy to work with in my opinion not
nearly as easy to work with it's
WordPress and it costs a lot of money to
use it every year and you have very
limited amount of users who can actually
edit things in X Ron WordPress way more
user-friendly and you can have unlimited
users for free so it was kind of a
no-brainer and like should we switch our
content management system like
absolutely another big thing is Ektron
the company is no longer company anymore
got bought out by another company so I'm
not even confident that it's really
receiving good support anymore
daddy says I'm new with this project
where do you get this data from and what
will this website do are you writing a
personal code and running it with
WordPress are we able to do that
okay so Nikki answered so I'm writing
the site and this is how Nikki says he's
writing the site and react and using
WordPress as a head of the CMS so yeah
I'm getting all the data from an old
database and I'm bringing it over in the
WordPress heidi says I heard that
WordPress there's most of the work but
you're writing your own code can you
explain a little yeah okay so the code
that you were saying was well - there
are two pieces of code that I showed you
one was the little bit of nodejs that we
are using to migrate data and then the
other thing I showed briefly was a PHP
plugin for WordPress so if you're not at
all familiar with WordPress you write
plugins in order to add functionality to
WordPress and in this case we're adding
post types so like if you have a post
and a blog that comes standard and
WordPress but if you want to add another
piece of a type of content in and you
can do that and create a custom post
type so that's what we're doing as a way
to organize data and it's better for the
people we need to edit it and then it's
better for us to be able to grab that
data and use it and reacts if we
separate it out and do a lot about you
know different post types different
categories and things so that's what I'm
doing and then there's a whole lot of
other code for a react site so we're
really only using WordPress for the
content management and not for display
at all so that's why we say it's a
headless WordPress install all the
display part of it is happening in
reacts
next story of what world says lol Ektron
do you do you have experience with X Ron
very few people have that experience
with it but I've never met anybody that
actually likes it I apologize if anybody
that actually developed Ektron is
watching in the stream um I'm sure that
when it came out it was probably very
state-of-the-art it's just by today's
standards it's not a great CMS Heidi
says why not use database directly
because we need a way for users who
don't really have any experience with
programming to be able to edit content
so WordPress is that that user interface
that's gonna allow them to edit content
and have it get saved new database so if
we just were going straight from the
database it would be difficult for users
to put data in I wouldn't want to put
data directly in a database and I know
how I still would rather have like a
nice WYSIWYG editor to do it in if it's
just some simple you know text content
changes so that's why we're doing it
like that hey Phoenix is here how you
doing
Heidi says can you share your list
please I'm interested and how you have
created it you mean my my checklist it
was just it's just check boxes in in
Google keep so it's not any like custom
thing it's just the standard that comes
with it
Chris Barker says I would I also would
advise people who are familiar with CSS
to look up CSS grid
Rachel Andrews is a good place to start
she created the spec grid but okay
actually that's a great I've been
meaning to learn more about CSS grid
lately
wife and I both we were just talking
about it yesterday so Rachel Andrews
I'll have to definitely look that up
thanks for that Chris Johnson John
Hanson says here - hey listening today
is I'm painting up a storm
awesome all right I don't know if any of
you know that John is a really talented
artist so he uses a man of many talents
programming and art and I'm sure other
things that I don't even know about
Nathan says really great content Jesse I
love this content and delivery wow I'm
really thank you for saying that I
really appreciate that son who says hi
hey how's it going Nathan says create a
solution for this that is generalized to
migrate any dataset it would be cool to
catalog the problems each way of an
ideal solution yeah yeah I started doing
this I guess before there was so much
data it was just so much data and it
wasn't categorized in the best way that
it was just really difficult to create a
solution that would allow me to just
bulk import data and really cover all
the different situations because some of
it just wasn't there wasn't the same set
of logic applied like routinely
throughout the development of the site
so different people who don't even work
here anymore added things in and
contract workers who never worked here
added things in and it sometimes be like
student workers working on it and so
it's just really difficult to come up
with something that would work for all
the data when it was just so I guess in
a sense like disorganized in some ways
all right let me take my time okay I
only have like two more minutes so I'm
gonna just try to get some of the
questions harsh it's asking me about JSF
I really like it I we can get in more
into it in Twitter today I'm actually
super busy so I apologize for not that
active on Twitter for any of you there
that you're trying to talk to me on any
social media today's just a busy day for
me
okay Phoenix says West bosses course on
CSS grade is also really awesome
alright I'm have to look into that as
well I haven't ever taken anything by
West boss but everybody says it's
awesome so I'm gonna have to try it out
John Hanson says someone's him a bit of
a birder as well Heidi says I thought
CMS is something used for both database
and showing all the content and it can't
be separated but you said using a CMS
for database why didn't use a device
directly yes so essentially you you can
separate them so that's what we've done
we've separated all the basically what a
user sees when they come to our website
is no longer controlled by WordPress so
essentially like you have lets you can't
really see my I was going to do some of
my hands but like imagine you have a
database that lives here the users who
are content editors interact with a
database through WordPress which sits
here and then over here separately they
get into over here separately sits our
react site and that's what users who are
coming to the website will see the react
site pulls data from the database
through WordPress so like no one ever
interacts directly with a database
WordPress is the intermediary between
the two that's both helping to pull the
data in in an organized way to our react
site and helping content editors to be
able to win any very easy way to edit
things that are in the database without
even even realizing there's a database
there so that's kind of what we're doing
so I think yeah I definitely have to go
now my meetings in just a few minutes so
anyway thank you all I apologize if I
didn't spend couldn't spend as much time
as I maybe normally would answering
questions feel free to always ask me
questions in the comments of the videos
on Twitter Instagram face
book email anything you like in any way
you can find me you can write me a
letter if you want I'm sure you can find
my address if you google me it's
probably not that hard you sent me a
text if you want to I know my phone
numbers out there as well but anyway I
have to go to a meeting thank you so
much everyone for all your great
encouragement and questions and I had a
great time doing the stream it
definitely woke me up a bit and I I'm
working on my home set up for streaming
hopefully I'll have it ready tomorrow so
I can stream from home I'll let y'all
know on Twitter for sure if I will be
streaming or not tomorrow so hopefully
see y'all tomorrow until then have a
great day